Nếu thường đau xương mù, ai người là bị miếng,
sẵn này tại Hà Nội, nhiều mây rất là mềm tượng thành phố đang chim trong xương mù.
Vì ngắm nhìn không còn tính, nóp nhả coa nó tẻ ở đâu.
Truy nhiên, theo các ấm dúc theo gỡ trên lợp không bị,
chỉ sâu ai cua đã chạm ngựng một số 2,
mức ăn hông thị, anh ngựng chực tiếp để xúc quả của hấp.
Tình chạm khối buổi xây đặc thiệt nhiều người cảm tế khó thơ,
khô buổi đau đầu.
Bой ninh người từ khu vực ít, ô nhận trên về thành phố xin xông,
sự tý đôi này, càng để gây ra các bánh tệ về ra và hồ hấp,
nếu không có thấp hiện phát bảo vệ phù hực.
Trong bối tìm đó, khu chăng UNK sau đề từ đúng mắt,
sẽ là một lượt trọt lý tưởng cho bạn,
nhờ thì kê bà lớp hàng quần có lớp tóc con hả tính xuất lọc bộ miệng hiệu quả,
khu chăng của chức liệu mềm mại xây đào m dài không lên sòn,
phố hợp ý thạm người thưởng trên trang điệp.
Phát phân viet có khu vô một chăm chiếm phếm mức dà tiếp tiếp,
thích hợp sự giúp cho gạch giá đình.
Chức tìm chào ôi yệu con kính ngày càng giúp trong,
vứ cự trọt thổ chăng triliệu là một trong những sài phát đơn giản,
nhưng cần thiết tế bảo vệ xức khuẻ bối này,
khá trộn quy tín, buồn ngày tạc đi.